to put this in the most simple
developmental model we-we-we gets we can
look at a individual and cultural
evolution as a leap from egocentric
which would be the the perspective of
the small baby right egocentric which
only I exist egocentric to ethnocentric
ethnocentric is when we are only
identified with our own bloodline our
own family our own tribe everyone else's
others so there's egocentric to
ethnocentric and to world centric but
before we get to world centric there's
two subcategories and one would be myth
eccentric because when we take the leap
from egocentric to ethnocentric from
from ethnocentric there's a leap -
there's a leap - when we begin to share
the same creation myth all the great
traditions share their own creation
stories so when we begin to share the
same creation stories creation myth with
other individuals our sense of being
connected suddenly leaps from just our
own bloodline to everyone else that
shares our particular religious
worldview so that would be a myth
eccentric and there's another
subcategory which would be nation
centric which is we have a strong sense
of national identity for example I'm an
American so there so so would be
egocentric - ethnocentric - myth
eccentric nation centric finally - world
centric and world centric it is it is
the level I'm showing but that most of
the people that would be listening to
this talk today which is when the
individual realizes that first and
foremost he or she is a human being a
member of the human species and a
citizen of the planet Earth while I also
am a member of a citizen of a particular
nation member of a particular ethnic
group have a particular personal ego
experienced I see all those things in
the context of being a human being a
member of the human family a citizen of
the planet Earth first and foremost so I
think that the the most important I
think revolution that has to happen is
this is this leap from ethnocentric in
terms of the world predicament were in
is a leap from ethnocentric and nation
centric and myth eccentric and nation
centric to world centric because when we
all realize they were
all human beings who are basically equal
as citizens of this one planet it's
going to become much easier for us to
come together and solve our collective
problems but there is a leap there there
is another there's a leap from world
centric to cosmos centric and cosmos
centric is what is when we begin to see
as I've been saying our own capacity for
consciousness and cognition as a product
of this deep time developmental process
then we begin to see everything is
happening including everything that's
happening on a global scale up from from
the perspective of the evolving cosmos
itself so the bigger our perspective the
more the more inclusive our way of
thinking is going to be unless exclusive
and of course the more human beings who
have a capacity to think in more
inclusive ways we're going to be
thinking about our problems and it's not
just the problems of a particular a
group of people our particular culture
but we're going to see everything that's
happening more in a global context
I think a lot of people are beginning to
to take to move towards this kind of
leave now I think for several reasons I
think because more and more people
realize that we're all facing a global
crisis right now especially in
relationship to global warming for
example and that simple fact is
compelling many people to to to
transcend ethnocentric differences and
also nation centric distinctions because
from the perspective of the global
warming we're all you know we're all
basically in the same mess even though
some of us are obviously going to be
suffering more than others
it's that plus the the the leap in our
era in our capacity to communicate and
because we can communicate at such a
speed in such a rate I think those two
factors very specifically are making it
unavoidably apparent that we're all
really part you know they were all part
of one world system one world process
and I also feel that that many many
individuals who who are products of this
post modern secular cultural environment
you know with values that are basically
based on materialism and narcissism do
yearn for a deeper context yearn for a
deeper sense of connection a sense of
connection that's inherently spiritual
in order to find a source of strength a
sort a sense of connectedness but and a
source of power
you know source of empowerment in which
to be able to to live this life you know
with with with courage you know in
passion